Hello, thank you for your help.
I would like to help a friend with our rife machine.
Are there any specific programs that you'd suggest
for neuropathy in their legs and feet?
Yeah, the neuropathy program.
So there's neuropathy programs in the true rife folder.
There's neuropathy programs in the atelier robin folder.
So either one of those could be helpful,
but always with any disease,
you always want to ask that one question, why?
So why do they have neuropathy?
Do they have diabetic neuropathy?
Do they have keyboard booster apathy?
Those are the things that you want to,
because you really want to deal with the cause, right?
So if the person has diabetic neuropathy,
well, you certainly can use the rife neuropathy programs,
but if you don't deal with the diabetes,
you're not going to really be ultimately helping that person.
If the person has neuropathy because they did chemo a year ago,
and they're done with that,
but now they have this neuropathy within my all means,
just jump into this,
then the causative factor is done.
You don't have to make changes there.
Also, detoxine as much as possible can be helpful
if it's something like that.
Not diabetes, but chemo therapy,
because chemo therapy induced neuropathy is from basically
the toxicity of the chemo therapy,
actually killing the nerves.
So helping detox would be helpful, too.
Sorry, I shouldn't have read the rest of the questions.
She said she's not diabetic,
and it's not from heavy metals.
It was diagnosed as unspecified neuropathy.
She also has two bad knees that the doctors say need replacing.
So still, I mean, she's got to get diagnosed.
There's some causes of neuropathy.
If it's in the hands and the feet,
or it's in her legs and her feet,
then it certainly could be just neurological
because of blood flow.
You do a full differential diagnosis
as the person have heart issues if they have weakness
in their heart.
It might not be getting good blood flow to their legs,
especially if she's got two bad knees
that could be blocking blood flow.
There could be stasis.
Even if the person has diabetes,
you could still have sugar stasis
in the lower extremities.
So that could be the cause of it.
Certainly looking at the rebuilder would be helpful, too,
but if you don't deal with the cause,
then that's not going to really be the answer.
But definitely, I would definitely use the right.
That's for sure.